[Music]
one show will have you on the edge of
your seats and leave you there this is
take your
[Music]
josè the gobi desert spans over which
two countries Jimmy I think my buzzers
broken
I know buzzers not broken still Jose's
turn Jose take your time don't let them
rush you in fact while Jose's thinking
that over let's get to know our other
contestants Becky tell me a little
something about yourself okay well I'm a
fifth grade school teacher I'm a proud
mom of two my husband Richie's an
engineer and I collect a vintage board
game I find this fascinating will you
tell me more over dinner after Neil was
born I got hurt real bad postpartum
depression
Richie was pushing me to go back to work
because he'd just taken a pay cut Oh
howdy my name is Kristi and I'll be your
waitress for tonight hey Kristi why
don't you tell us a little something
about yourself oh okay I know the answer
so you know I experimented a lot in
college yeah but I really think that I
know who I am now you know and I have a
blog
bori who know hell from the audience
please can I make a call
absolutely as long as the other person
knows to help you with a question use
your red phone okay that's fine I just
have to change an appointment ah I
haven't seen one of these in a while I'm
Dave by the way Wow you think it would
have gone to voicemail by now we
apologize to anyone tuning in for the
NBA Finals we're gonna have to do a
hover the cats great can I pass nope
then my answer is Africa and Egypt that
is incorrect
that means the clock resets and it's a
brand-new gag
all right Oh same same question
take your
[Music]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]